bien yo soy bea' hardman y estoy aquí
con salman khan hola y estamos hablando
de cómo podemos pensar en números
y cuál es la forma más natural de pensar
en ellas me dice que me va a poner a
prueba en este momento sí así es si
vamos
voy a usar la pluma oficiales en la
pantalla y bien necesitas un poco de
plata que necesite entrenamiento aquí
abajo está dibujando parece una pizza
y cuál es la prueba bien
estás divirtiendo aquí está una recta
numérica
aunque estos mejores que vimos aquí el 1
aquí va
un millón
y ahora te voy a dar la pluma aquí está
donde está
milk donde está el miami donde está el
milk puedes pensar en ella de varias
maneras ya veo a dónde quieres ir
primero te voy a decir lo que me vino a
la mente pues mi primera reacción era la
de poner el 1000 aquí pero luego algo
brinco en mi mente
en mi mente analítica
bueno así saber que si hay una respuesta
correcta para este problema en la que
podemos pensar así que bueno donde
estaba 1000 en esta línea numérica bueno
vamos a pedir un millón entre miles mil
vamos a ver que hay cuántas veces que
hablar o es un nivel estados como un
décimo en realidad es un milésimo
estaría más bien aquí y es casi
intersectoriales de la diferencia entre
uno y el mil están muy muy cerquita
esto es fascinante porque habré pensado
que estaba aquí si es interesante pensar
porque nos imaginamos que el 1000 está
más cerca del millón de lo que en
realidad está esto no sucede todo el
tiempo pues no estamos acostumbrados a
pensar en las diferencias entre 1000 y
un trillón estamos más acostumbrados a
pensar en las diferencias entre el 1 y
el 2 o entre el 2 y el 3 o entre el 1 y
el tiempo esto pero pensamos que entre 1
y 2 hay una gran diferencia doble que se
doble es una gran diferencia de oriente'
efecto la diferencia entre 9 y 10 es la
misma distancia cuando estamos viendo en
la misma escala que el 1 y el 2
pero cuando pensamos en cosas de la vida
real la diferencia entre el 1 y el 10 no
se ve demasiado no pero entre 1 y 2 es
muchísimo es el doble así que ahora
tenemos que pensar en escalas las únicas
que esto es de lo que se trata así que
lo que sugiere es que nuestra mente
humana está acostumbrada a pensar de una
manera lineal aquí tenemos el uno por
aquí estaría el 10 luego el 20
siempre estamos acostumbrados a pintar
este tipo de cosas en matemáticas así es
como lo dibujamos en el papel
normalmente pero realmente no tiene
mucho sentido en la forma en como
nosotros pensamos en ello que la
diferencia entre 5 millones y 5 millones
con 10 es nada
en cambio la diferencia entre una y 10
es demasiado claro
carlos los múltiplos importan más más
que las distancias por supuesto y aquí
es donde la escala logarítmica tiene
sentido eso es y es por eso que vemos
mucho de la escala logarítmica
la vida real de hecho los músicos usando
el piano lo ven como una escala
logarítmica
aquí vamos a ver nuestro dibujo nos mira
eso es un piano nos permite aquí tenemos
el c
aquí tenemos la d
y hay una distancia entre estas 2
y aquí tenemos la clave cuando
escuchamos estas dos notas juntas pues
tiene la misma distancia estas dos que
estas otras dos
pero si se ven las frecuencias realmente
de sonido
estas distancias no son las mismas si
cierto no tenemos los números sobre
estas no es un buen ejemplo porque no sé
de frecuencias bueno les voy a dar un
ejemplo donde pueda poner números que es
la diferencia entre esta octava y esta
otra octava siesta es ser bueno de hecho
es x lo tachamos
digamos x la frecuencia x 40 no sabemos
los números bueno digamos que ésta tiene
300 m hearts
esta otra frecuencia digamos que es de
600 600 bien así que es el doble verde
1200 megahertz
así que estamos viendo que se duplican
acá la diferencia entre estos dos son
300 la diferencia entre estos dos es de
600 pero cuando estamos escuchando las
octavas la diferencia entre estas dos
pues no es evidente que esta sea la
mitad que esta otra
la diferencia entre una octava y la otra
octava pues debería ser una octava claro
el tono nuestra percepción del tono es
logarítmica es fundamentalmente
logarítmica si queremos tener todas las
notas en un piano una junto a otra
tomando en cuenta su frecuencia tenemos
aquí por ejemplo una tecla y otra tecla
acá la siguiente
y la siguiente pues bueno ya no entra en
el pizarrón así que los fabricantes de
pianos los hacen de una manera
logarítmica pues sí porque nosotros
pensamos en la escala logarítmica si
fueran lineales las teclas tendrían que
ser cada vez más anchas
viendo con las teclas anchas eso sería
genial santo es bueno pero no pensamos
en esto no escuchamos así y no solo es
el tono también están las magnitudes de
las frecuencias y bueno tenemos los
decibeles que es una escala logarítmica
nuestros sentidos perciben naturalmente
la escala logarítmica por ejemplo si
pensamos en la diferencia en el volumen
de como estoy hablando ahorita y como
estoy hablando ahorita que es más alto
pues también percibimos la distancia en
el volumen pues también sentimos como
una distancia
esos difíciles para crear imágenes que
vemos en esta vida aquí las cosas
al gritar si es parte como de un juego
fascinante y bueno esto fue lo que nos
hizo hablar de estas cosas perfecto es
bastante bueno cuando vemos la
diferencia entre digamos que un millón
de dólares y diez millones de dólares
es la forma en la que el mundo sigue
estas percepciones claro son estos
maravillosos